welcome back to the stronger by science
podcast
in today's episode we have two big
research review segments in the first
one
we look at the idea of p ratios it's
commonly said that you should get lean
before you do a muscle gaining phase the
idea is
if you get leaner you'll become more
insulin sensitive this will
increase your p ratio and potentiate the
hypertrophy that you achieve during the
subsequent muscle gaining phase
in the research review segment we look
at all the evidence for and against
that concept after that greg does a
research review segment all about the
concept of
ischemic preconditioning after that we
do a quick
q a segment where we talk about a few
very applied very practical questions
and that wraps up the episode which is
the final episode
of season three so we are gonna take a
little break after this episode but we
will be back
better than ever as always we hope you
enjoyed the episode
and we'll be back soon
[Music]
welcome back to the stronger by science
podcast this is your one and only host
eric trexler but
today i am going to be joined by a
special temporary guest co-host his name
is greg knuckles greg thank you for
joining me today
yeah thanks for having me i uh i was
surprised
and delighted by the invite absolutely
well last time you did a great job i got
a lot of really good
uh really good fan mail and and so i
said hey we'll we'll bring him back
again and see if uh
see if we can recreate that that
lightning in a bottle so um
we'll see how it goes um now this is
going to be our last episode of the
season
we're going to be taking some time off
uh
you know a little bit of a break and
then focusing on getting some written
content done
so that's going to be cool rest assured
we are going to be working very hard for
the stronger by science audience
making sure we get some stuff put
together um
so yeah hopefully this will be a good
episode we'll take a little break and
then we'll be back
um before we get into the content and
the good news and stuff today
uh i do want to do it's not a selling
out segment because in a way it's almost
the inverse
because i'm going to plug a supplement
company that we don't make money from
so taking money out of our own pockets
obviously we financially
have hitched our wagon to
bulksupplements.com
you go there for your supplement needs
and what's the code
sbs pod and you get a discount there
uh but i have to give a shout out to
elemental
formulations who uh we don't make any
money from them which is
honestly criminal but uh but i'm on the
advisory board there
and they just uh just got rolling a
couple weeks ago i think
um and so that's uh that's omar omar
esof
and uh ben escrow that's their new
supplement company
and this morning i got a package in the
mail it was
a product called utopia and it was
really good timing
um you know so i spent the entire
morning reading about a bunch of stuff i
don't fully understand
and that usually scrambles my brain and
puts me in a position where i'm unable
to
speak and sound like i'm lucid
and alert so uh utopia
it's their product that's you know it's
kind of like a
uh it's got some caffeine in there and
all that stuff so uh if
i sound uh conversational
in this episode then i think they
deserve a little bit of credit
um if this is just our worst episode
ever
and and i just sound like a complete
dumbass
then shame on them honestly shame on
them
i'm kidding but but it's it's a really
cool company and
i've been offered you know people have
asked me to be on
uh the advisory board for supplement
companies and i've i've always said no
up to this point
but uh but they're good dudes ben is a
terrific formulator
omar's fine i like him and uh
and what what a ringing endorsement
omar and i just we just constantly give
each other a hard time but
no omar's great and and i really like
they have a bunch of third-party testing
stuff on their site
you can like look into the um you know
the the quality and purity of the
product so
it's good stuff so giving them a little
shout out um
and now moving on to some good news okay
so
uh this is kind of a bunch of personal
good news
this uh this week i feel like you know
the whole rest of the world
whatever man it's all about us today so
personal good news first of all
we've added some really awesome new
coaches to the stronger by science team
recently so stronger by science we have
a whole team of coaches
really really excellent people we've
added a few
recently so not long ago we added
melissa wen
she was actually our first intern at
stronger by science she's a registered
dietitian
really fantastic so we're super excited
about having her on the team
and then even more recently we added two
new coaches within the last few weeks
uh one with stephen mack he is a really
really experienced personal trainer
played football at missouri when he was
there he was training under brian mann
and pat
ivey who really know their stuff so
we're stoked to have him on board
we also got colby souza who has kind of
been
trained under the tutelage of our our
dear friends the good doctors mike
zordos and eric helms
so colby's down in new zealand right now
working on his phd with helms
uh knows a ton of stuff about
powerlifting and bodybuilding so
you know we're stoked the team has
gotten better in the last couple months
uh other good news personally uh my
2012 what year is it 2021
i think so yeah my my habits so far we
talked
about those last episode uh they're
going well honestly
uh sleep habits have been way better uh
i
am a little bit over caffeinated today
i'll admit that was a slip
up my bad um you know i don't think the
instructions for utopia said you know
drink a pot of coffee and then take it
um so so that that is my mistake but but
pretty doing a pretty good job so far
not staying up super late
uh and doing all the good things
exercising a little bit more regularly
so
good stuff there uh what about you greg
any good news
uh yes but i
i want to tell a quick story um related
to
getting a new supplement and maybe
taking a little bit too much of it
so uh way way back in the day
um i'm not gonna name names in this
story
but uh i was working at a gym
and they wanted to put together
some supplements um and so
i and they entrusted that to me probably
not the best call
uh but basically i just went on
examine.com
and checked out uh the human effect
matrix for
a lot of the like more common things
that might be
marketed as uh as like fat burner
supplements
one of them was a fat burner and so you
know obviously it's going to be
primarily caffeine-based because
you know it can elevate metabolic rate
to some degree
suppress appetite a little bit so i mean
basically it was caffeine and some other
stuff
um and uh
we so like we we got labels printed for
the bottle and everything
uh we had scoops included for the
uh recommended dosage and the
recommended dosage was really really
small
it was a really small bottle um
and the recommended dose was like it was
like either a quarter teaspoon or an
eighth of a teaspoon
it wasn't much and that was going to
give you like 300 milligrams of caffeine
uh and so anyway the uh the shipment
comes in like the bottles arrive at the
gym
and uh one of the folks was like oh man
fat burner there's a lot of stimulants
in this right and i was like
yep uh and they were like would this
work as a pre-workout
i said yeah i mean if i was trying to
make a pre-workout there there would be
some other things
in there that that aren't in there but i
mean if you're looking for a stimulant
it's a stimulant
and they were like okay awesome sweet uh
and so
before i could say anything um they
just like opened it up there was like a
smoothie bar at the gym
they grabbed like a plastic spoon that
would be
like given with a smoothie and uh
just like took a scoop with the plastic
spoon and i think put about as much
powder in their mouth as they would
typically use
with like most pre-workouts on the
market um which
just eyeballing it was probably five
of the recommended dosages of this
product
uh so we're talking probably about a
gram and a half of caffeine um
and so you know caffeine takes
somewhere between like 30 minutes and an
hour and a half to really kick in
um and so you know they they started
warming up
and like 30 minutes after ingesting it
they were bouncing off the walls
uh and actually had a fantastic workout
hit some pr's
hit some big numbers um very very hyper
very loud hyping up everyone else in the
weight room uh
and then uh just like
all of a sudden everyone kind of
realized like
man the weight room has gone eerily
silent
um and uh it was because
the person who had been bringing all of
the energy up to that point
was now nowhere to be found
and basically we uh we looked for them
a little bit uh found them curled up uh
under a table in the office
and uh just in very very bad shape
um and uh
so i i my first thought was like oh [ __ ]
like do we need to call
an ambulance uh and then like i did some
googling to see like
how much caffeine would be lethal
um and like they were well below that
dosage
uh so i was just like well
you're just gonna have to ride this one
out uh but they were just like
laying there shivering with like cold
sweat
pouring down their face in very very bad
shape
um in anyway i thought that was uh
it was it was originally terrifying
before i
knew how much caffeine it took to
actually kill a person uh and then in
hindsight it turned out to be something
pretty funny
uh all of which and they were fine by
the way
all of which is to say the moral of that
story is uh
yeah too much caffeine sometimes has bad
effects
yeah well see i had taken this product
before
utopia that i took this morning and uh i
loved it
i got a couple tubs of it way back in
the day i was years ago
and uh so so i knew what to expect but i
forgot that it does
pack a bit a bit of a punch so like
you're not supposed to drink a ton of
coffee and then and then take it but
like i drank all my coffee this morning
and then it arrived in the mail and i
was just too excited
so so i i knew that i was like yeah i
shouldn't have had that coffee and this
but uh
but here we are and uh i don't have any
regrets i'm
doubling down on my decisions no fair
enough all right so uh what's your good
news
uh so my good news is uh
something fairly minor but next week uh
i'm taking my first break in
close to a year and a half so october
2019
it took about a week mostly off of work
and since then i don't think i've taken
more than a day off of work
and i'm pretty sure the only times i
took a day off of work
were thanksgiving and christmas um
as we've talked about on the podcast
before we do not
condone poor work-life balance but i at
least speaking for myself have
absolutely terrible work-life balance um
but yeah next week uh gonna finally get
a chance to
chill out unplug a little bit uh spend
some quality time with my wife um
and yeah i'm i'm really really looking
forward to that
and i think that will be good all right
good stuff so how about
some feats of strength yeah let's do it
um
so i have two this time around
uh and these are two recurring feats of
strength people
um so as consistent listeners know by
now
uh the feats of string segment is
partially the julius maddox watch
segment
uh julius maddox quite famously is on
a quest to become the first 800 pound
bencher
uh and some of his recent training lifts
in his current training cycle
uh include benching 710
for a triple that's 322 pounds
uh and 650 for a set of seven
uh or 322 kilos that's 710.
uh and 650 for seven that's 295 kilos
for seven reps
uh i i don't need to add commentary for
that
those are just absolutely batshit crazy
bench numbers
um he is ahead of where he was at this
point in his last bench cycle
um where if memory serves he took
a pretty solid crack at 800 and missed
um
i mean i never bet against him at this
point i i
fully anticipate 800 is gonna fall in
2021
uh and i'm really really looking forward
to it he is
unsurprisingly looking strong as [ __ ]
uh and second uh yang zhu rin
who a lot of people know know as you you
wren
he is a 93 kilo competitor
uh in the usapl uh in ipf affiliates
he recently posted a
just absolutely bonkers training lift
uh he pulled 905 pounds or about 410
kilos
with straps uh on the deadlift
and that is so just to put that number
in perspective
um so for me like i got into
powerlifting
uh at a time when you know people
from the 70s to 90s still held most of
the raw records
um and like the number that
basically everyone thought would never
fall was ed cohn's 220 deadlift record
he pulled 903 at 220.
um and
that number has since fallen uh but now
you know obviously uh yang zubrin pulled
this
with straps uh and not in a meet but i
mean
just the fact that a weight class below
uh he's he's putting up comparable
numbers
really under any circumstance uh is just
bad [ __ ] crazy
um and that's also just
just outrageous progress for him i think
his best deadlift in a meet
uh is 749 or 340 kilos
which he did i think back in 2018
uh and around a year ago
i think we talked about this on the
podcast he he pulled his first 800 with
straps
thereabouts um and
now he's up over 900 i have no idea if
he'll ever hit a number like that in a
meet or
you know what his grip can take if if
he's a grip limited deadlifter
um but again uh let's just assume
that he does put 900 plus up
uh in the uh
93 kilo class or he uh he did the lift
at a body weight of 196
uh which is 89 kilos so it it would fall
under the 198 or 90 kilo class
uh so just looking at those numbers um
this would be the all-time world record
uh for untested powerlifting and he
competes tested
uh current world record is 400 kilos or
881 by taylor wollum so
uh this bests that by about 10 kilos
about
uh 24 pounds uh and it would be 80
pounds ahead
of anything that a tested lifter has
ever done
in the same weight class uh and that's
jesse norris he pulled
8 24 back in 2014 i believe uh after
jesse norris
the next best a tested lifter has done
in that weight class is 771 or 350 kilos
um so anyway i
man if we saw if we saw a 900 plus
deadlift
from uh uu ren in 2021 or even 2022
or just at any point or by anyone in the
198 class
drug free or not that would be an
absolutely momentous lift
uh and the fact that a tested lifter
even with straps
is putting that up uh at that weight
class
is a enormous leap forward
from even just five years ago what i
think
anyone in the sport expected to see um
so great lifting from him uh and you
know hopefully when he can get back on
the platform again
we uh we see some big numbers from them
all right good stuff i i gotta
i gotta be honest i'm very much looking
forward to uh
to tracking julius maddox as he
approaches 800. i've been looking
forward to that
you know ever since he took a crack at
it last year because
it seemed like when we first started
doing feats of strength every week we
were just talking about his
his newest pr um so man when he hits 800
that's going to be
that's going to be wild and you got to
believe it's going to be this year you
know i i i really think it will be
i i if if i had to to bet on it i'd say
it's it's going to be 2021 for sure
yeah and i mean that's another number as
well that just
uh even even five years ago
just seemed completely inconceivable uh
cause
uh scott mendelsohn when he hit 715 back
in the day
uh like he was far and away ahead of
everyone at the time
uh he only beat the world record by five
pounds
james henderson had done 710 back in the
90s
but like no one was particularly close
to 715 at the time
and then when eric spodo
hit 722 folks were like damn
pushing the frontier by seven pounds
that's
that's something uh and then sarah chev
came up and hit 738
folks were just like jesus christ this
guy like
700 seemed like a limit and this guy's
pushing
into the mid 700s uh beat the old record
by
what's that 16 pounds like
man that's outrageous and now not that
far into the future
someone's like legitimately knocking on
the door of 800
uh like i don't think anyone really
expected to see an 800 raw bench ever
uh and now i mean i i think if you're a
betting person
uh you know your your odds would be
pretty good
if you wanted to bet on that number
falling in 2021 which
is just bonkers to me yeah
all right so moving on uh we've got a an
unconventional
segment coming up so in the past we've
done
segments where we discuss a stronger by
science article
so we'll write the article put it on the
website and then kind of talk about some
of the chatter
in this case we're doing it in reverse
order right we've got a break coming up
uh so so we won't be able to discuss
this most likely in the immediate
aftermath of the publication of this
article so it's kind of just talking
through the premise of the article and
kind of
i don't know outlining it verbally
because it's not fully formed you know
it's just kind of like the preliminary
observations but it's a really
fascinating topic that has really
uh taken control of my my brain lately
i i kind of keep thinking about it and
keep going back to it
and uh and revisiting the topic and
reading more so
the topic is something we've alluded to
on the podcast before
so i think it was episode 49. we had
a question from a listener and the
question was
is is there an easy way to to judge if
i'm gaining too much fat during a bulk
and in the process of answering that we
talked about this concept of the p ratio
uh for bulking or for building muscle
and so the p ratio uh essentially is the
proportion
of weight gained that is gained as lean
mass so you know the amount of lean mass
gained
uh relative to the total amount of
weight gained
and so if you have a high p ratio during
a bulk that means you put on a ton of
muscle
and minimal body fat if you have a low p
ratio then it means you put on a bunch
of weight but very little of it was
actually lean tissue very little of it
was
was muscle and so where this gets
interesting
is there's kind of a a common
theory or hypothesis within the
evidence-based lifting community
that as your body fat gets higher
you become more insulin resistant and so
then your muscle cells
become less responsive to insulin
and that has a has an impact on nutrient
partitioning such that
nutrients are essentially diverted away
from muscle
and the result of that according to this
hypothesis is that
if you put on a lot of body fat and
you're trying to bulk and your body fat
percentage is high
you're going to have a lower p ratio
while bulking so for a given amount of
weight gain
a relatively smaller proportion of it is
going to be
muscle tissue or lean mass and the idea
is that you can
utilize this so basically if you do
a cut or a mini cut between bulking
cycles
you can get your body fat lower you can
restore your insulin sensitivity and
this would put you in a position where
you can actually potentiate
hypertrophy in the following bulk or the
next muscle gaining
phase so that's kind of the the theory
of it
and i wrote a mass article last month
where i kind of
took a deep dive into this topic and
even after the mass article has been
done
you know greg you and i have been
continuing to look deeper and deeper
into this evidence and
on the front end i don't want it to seem
like this is like
some vendetta that i have where i'm like
like i need to destroy this idea because
that's really not the case but
i'm just kind of coming at it from a
skeptical
perspective because like theoretically
the null hypothesis would be
you can bulk at any body fat level right
so the burden of proof would basically
be
someone's got to convince me that this p
ratio thing
really pans out you know like the the
easiest position to defend is
probably doesn't matter well and for me
uh
arguing against this position is uh
very inconvenient and not in my best
interest because back in
like 2013 2014 i wrote an article
uh on what was at the time string theory
now stronger by science
uh basically arguing for this that uh
you should get lean before you bulk for
uh the reasons that are about to be
discussed like you know you're
you're going to have better nutrient
partitioning you're going to gain
a larger proportion of lean mass you'll
be able to build muscle faster
um so at one time i did
wholeheartedly believe in that idea i
put it out in the world
uh the article was well received was
getting a lot of traffic
um so i
wish that i could disagree with a lot of
the things that eric is about to say
uh because i do not particularly like
the taste of crow
yeah and that's the thing that's
interesting about this this
kind of hypothesis is it's been very
uh widely accepted within you know our
little corner of the evidence-based
lifting community and so you know like i
said i i
have no interest in tearing it down like
i i don't have to defend any position on
this i'm
i'm completely unbiased in the approach
um but i am viewing it from a pretty
skeptical perspective and i think i'm
i'm finding it harder and harder to
justify the hypothesis for reasons we'll
get into but i am open to being
talked out of this um so this is just
kind of the the first
impressions of taking a deep dive into
this concept so
my knee-jerk reaction to this concept as
somebody with no position to defend
no bias no skin in the game was this
concept doesn't really feel right to me
which
that's not going to be the extent of the
evidence we discuss we'll get into
deeper stuff but
you know we've talked about you know the
dreamer bulk right
just going for it eating everything
lifting like crazy and i've heard a lot
of people who have some
regret about a dream or bulk but the one
regret i've never heard like people say
oh
i felt like crap i couldn't get up a
flight of stairs without getting winded
i put on way too much fat that i didn't
need to gain but the one thing i've
never ever heard in my life
is i didn't get big and strong during it
like that that's the one thing i've
never heard after a dreamer bulk and
theoretically if something is messing
with your p
ratio during a bulk effectively what
that means is
it's impairing muscle gain right like i
mean we i don't think anyone's
suggesting that this fat gain is kind of
appearing out of nowhere
completely separate from energy balance
it's you put in a bunch of energy and
very little muscle was built in the
process
right so i think it's fair to say that
an impaired p ratio during a bulk
is essentially an impairment of muscle
hypertrophy
right is that fair yeah or or or at the
very least
it would imply that to achieve the same
rate of muscle hypertrophy you would
have to gain
you would have to gain weight
dramatically faster and put on
dramatically more fat for the same
hypertrophic outcome
yeah so in in a given period of time
right
so there are other reasons why this just
didn't really feel
right to me um so i come at this you
know a lot of
my work as a grad student i did
you know some papers about weight regain
you know so uh
looking at after someone gets pretty
shredded
and then they start regaining weight
after that what what happens what does
that body composition
look like in the weight regain period
and when you look at the weight regain
literature which is how this concept is
being utilized people are saying you
should cut then bulk
that's weight regain you know usually in
that literature
and those these researchers don't give a
damn about bulking you know so they're
coming from a totally different
perspective
what we're trying to do there is like p
ratios get worse
in in weight regain like there's really
one of two options when you look at the
weight regain literature
uh you know if you look at physique
athletes which we did with some research
uh the p ratio was awful after a
bodybuilding competition uh
there's very preferential regain of fat
and then when you look at people who are
untrained who are
you know trying to get to a healthier
bmi maybe
right get to a lower bmi in untrained
folks who have a bmi over
you know 30 and and above what we'll see
is if they have really substantial
weight loss
their p ratio might get worse if it's
minor weight loss their p ratio
probably won't be affected but we do not
see a consistent effect where people
lose weight and then have an improved p
ratio
when they start gaining weight after
that so for me i'm like wait a minute
i my my kind of frame of reference for
this is completely inverted
because i'm coming at it from from the
weight regained literature
another reason it didn't make sense to
me is you know if we are
assuming that there's some degree of you
know
if having high body fat makes muscle
building an uphill battle
it's hard to reconcile that with the
fact that a lot of the
the athletes with the highest fat free
mass index on the planet
they they have high body fat like that's
a pretty consistent observation
um and another thing that kind of rubbed
me the wrong way about this
is and this isn't strong evidence but
it's just kind of a knee-jerk reaction
which is like
we've been here before you know that
these
theories about nutrient partitioning
that are built on a mechanistic
understanding of insulin in one tissue
this essentially is the carb insulin
model of
obesity revisited right so the whole
idea
why do people get obese it's because we
eat carbs insulin goes up it drives fat
in drives calories into fat cells the
lean tissues and circulation all those
nutrients go down
and there's this kind of starvation
response begging for more nutrients to
come into the system
so like i get really nervous about
extrapolating these insulin mechanisms
and assuming that there are no other
factors at play
right so that's the starting point but i
think
before we talk about you know the actual
evidence uh
for or against it we should figure out
where this idea came from in the first
place and i think
with this hypothesis it's really
informative really instructive so
by all accounts i can find the real
impetus for this idea goes back to a
paper by forbes
and uh he published a couple of review
papers
kind of establishing this concept that
it
if you over feed people people who
had low body fat at the time at the
beginning of that overfeeding
they tend to gain more lean mass
proportionally
and then people who had a lot of body
fat at the at the time of that
overfeeding
they don't seem to gain really much lean
mass at all
when they're overfed and so he kind of
plotted this curve and there's this
classic figure that you see all over the
place on the internet
and one of the things that strikes me
about this figure and this is not a
criticism of forbes necessarily but
greg this figure is hard to interpret
like if you look at it there's five
points on the figure
but if you look at the and these are i
guess aggregated mean values
but there's five points on the figure
but there are several studies that are
cited
uh in the caption of the figure so
i'm still not a hundred percent certain
exactly what studies these data points
came from
and how they were grouped together and
aggregated but what i can tell you for
certain is that
several of uh of the uh
data points going into this figure the
studies contributing data to the
analysis
were done in people who are recovering
from anorexia
and so we're talking about overfeeding
in a group of people who have
severe clinically relevant atrophy of
lean tissues
so there is uh a fairly atypical
compared to the the general population
uh there's a major stimulus there for
the accretion of lean tissue it is
literally a matter of life and death
right like there there is a reason for
lean tissue to be added there
so that's one of the things that jumped
out and another study that gets cited
there
as potentially contributing data to the
figure oh and if if i can just uh
tall something in real quick just to
clear up a point of potential confusion
sure uh there's a reasonably well-known
contemporary
uh sports nutrition researcher named
scott forbes
uh don't address questions about this
paper
no uh this this is an older paper by a
researcher named gilbert forbes
yes so just making sure that's clear
yeah yeah don't uh
you know pester poor scott about
this um but anyway uh another study that
appears to have contributed data
for for this particular figure uh was
done in like a really extreme
weight loss intervention where the term
they used was total starvation
and like they had people losing 50 60
kilograms
and then observing the refeeding stage
and like i said i mean
if you're losing 50 60 kilograms based
on what we know in the weight regained
literature you're probably going to have
a
terrible p ratio in terms of that weight
regain
if all all other factors are held
constant
so looking at this figure i think the
thing that jumps out to me
and i should note that kevin hall did a
kind of revisited approach to this data
with similar models but the main things
that jump out from the forbes paper and
the kevin hall paper who are both great
researchers by the way this is not
being critical of them but there are
several instances of data
coming from people who are recovering
from anorexia or coming out of these
really extreme weight loss interventions
but most importantly
there is no data coming from people who
lift weights
and for me i'm thinking you know the
main driver of
what kind of tissue we gain during a
bulk is what's the training stimulus
and so so to be extrapolating data from
people who are not doing any exercise
whatsoever
is a huge leap yeah and i mean you're
dealing with different starting points
as well like if uh
if someone's either anorexic or they've
just gone on a total starvation diet
odds are pretty decent that they've lost
way way more
lean mass in the process than someone
who has had a consistent
resistance training stimulus as they've
been
gradually and hopefully safely taking
weight off
so yeah the the process of over feeding
is different over feeding with a
training stimulus and over training or
in
over feeding without a training stimulus
not the same thing
and and the point you're starting at the
physiological starting point prior to
the overfeeding
also very very different than you know
what
most people listening to this podcast
probably have in mind
when they talk about a bulk yeah and
another thing that comes into play with
these models is that they are completely
cross-sectional in nature
so they they are not indicating hey you
can kind of slide your way
up and down this curve by manipulating
your body composition and then bulking
this is just saying like hey if we bring
in somebody who has 35
body fat and then we over feed them
without resistance training
they don't seem to gain a lot of lean
mass and
i don't know why they would uh is kind
of
the first concern there but but also uh
you wonder these people who at baseline
happen to have
you know higher body fat levels is it
potentially some intrinsic thing about
their physiology
where you know they have higher body fat
levels because they are indeed more
likely to gain fat when overfed
i mean that that kind of is the process
of developing obesity
right so with these cross-sectional
types of approaches
it's hard to separate that and also hard
to justify that this will
necessarily pan out in a longitudinal
sense
and another thing you'll notice with
these models
is that the relationship is not linear
it's far from it
when you look at the models especially
from the kevin hall paper
the beginning of the curve is like
vertical and then it gets
very very very flat and so what you'll
see
and and by the way that the curve isn't
like a perfect fit
and so like there's a great uh a great
figure from the kevin hall paper looking
at weight gain
and from from two people who both have
you know
10 or 15 kilograms of fat mass at the
beginning of the overfeeding period
it literally their p ratios span from as
high as the p
ratios get in the entire collection of
data to
almost as low as they get in the entire
collection of data
so if you just said like well hey if i
if i'm starting this with 12 kilograms
of fat mass how am i going to do
you'd say you will either have
approximately the highest or
approximately the lowest p ratio or
somewhere in between
yeah and just to put numbers on that
like uh it
ranges from somewhere just below 0.8 to
somewhere
in the neighborhood of 0.2 so basically
that's saying like
oh yeah if you're starting with 12 kilos
of fat mass and you're going to gain
10 kilos of body weight how much of that
is gonna be muscle
somewhere between two and eight kilos um
which like you said that's uh that's
quite the range and it's just not
actionable
you know like there's not much we can do
with that and from my perspective
looking at the way that these data kind
of fit this curve
what it basically says is if you
have pretty high body fat already
and you are not engaged in resistance
training and you're intentionally over
feeding
you're probably not going to gain a lot
of muscle
and or a lot of lean mass and i i think
that that is a very intuitive
thing to uh to conclude i mean there's
there's no stimulus there
for adding lean mass you know so
so that's kind of where this thing
starts and i think a lot of people have
said hey this p
ratio relationship it's been shown in
several studies
you know not super worried about the
context i'm sure this pans out just fine
for lifters
but what we did when we were kind of
diving into this mass article
is we're like well let's look for some
relevant lines of evidence and see if if
we kind of
test this hypothesis with some different
perspectives and approaches does it seem
to hold up
and so uh one area that you might go
down
when you're looking at this this concept
is you know do we conclusively know
that having higher body fat impairs
your muscle protein synthesis response
acutely
to uh you know to over feeding or
protein feeding or resistance training
and there's a really great review paper
by beals and colleagues that
that looks into this and if you look at
the collection of the the research in
this
area you'll find that people with higher
body fat do seem to have a blunted
muscle protein synthesis response to
acute protein feeding
but they also seem to have lower muscle
protein breakdown
in those studies and so the the overall
effect
on protein balance doesn't seem to be
particularly notable
and that kind of pans out because
we don't look at people with high body
fat per se because muscle protein
balance is a continuous process
you know it's it's always maintaining
those lean proteins and the
lean proteins the proteins of the body
right that's
people get really nitpicky if you say
lean protein or lean muscle or something
man get getting on a supplement company
board has uh
has already started affecting your
linguistic patterns yeah yeah that's
that's terrible but i caught myself so i
can't be held accountable
um but yeah we have to continue
maintaining protein balance it's a
continuous thing when we look at people
untrained people lean versus obese
we don't see uh you know a lack of lean
body mass in people with
obesity in in fact quite the opposite
tends to be higher lean body mass so
the the most important thing about that
review paper in my opinion is that
they did look at two studies where there
was a resistance training component
and without getting too deep into the
details uh
it's two studies that go opposite
directions it's it's pretty equivocal
one said yeah resistance training with
protein it looks like responses are
are blunted in people with higher body
fat the other said
it doesn't look like they're blunted it
looks like it's pretty similar
um but neither of them were able to pin
down a
a mechanism you know so so even the one
that that indicated
you know there there are some blunted uh
responses when we do the combination of
resistance training with
protein in people with higher body fat
they looked at all these different
potential mechanisms that might
contribute and
kind of came up short they said okay
well the synthesis rates were lower
but we can't necessarily pin it on any
particular aspect of their physiology
so so that is equivocal at best that
particular line of of evidence
um number two like i mentioned um
if if we're going to say that insulin
resistance has some kind of inhibitory
effect on the accretion of lean mass you
know the two questions would be
you know for untrained people do people
with
obesity tend to have lower lean mass
than leaner individuals and and the
answer is
no we tend to see the opposite slightly
higher
amounts of lean body mass and people
with obesity
and then again talking about athletes
you know do we see that
at a certain level of body fat
percentage that it becomes
increasingly difficult to add lean mass
that doesn't really seem to pan out with
the cross-sectional literature on
which athletes tend to have a ton of
fat-free mass
and it doesn't pan out with the fact i
mean greg we've talked about this before
uh you know offensive linemen defensive
linemen super heavyweight lifters
uh you know these athletes who have high
body fat percentage
they still make great gains you know
after they've already
found themselves in a position of having
high body fat percentage it's not like
they got there
and now lean mass gains are off the
table so so these observations don't
really seem to pan out when we look at
those cross-sectional
looks at body composition in people with
varying degrees
of body fat and an extension of that
in the mass article i took a look at
some of the literature with american
football players which i thought was
kind of a
a really nice way to look at the
question because we've got this group of
people
who when you look at an american
football team
we know that there's going to be
position groups who have very low body
fat and pretty high body fat
there's a huge spread and we know that
they're training in the same gym
they're eating at the same dining hall
they're getting trained by the same
folks
like i mean there's a lot of stuff there
that's kind of
being controlled in this natural
experiment it's not a perfect
look at it because there might be some
different training focuses
from position group to position group
but it's not a bad
model for looking at this question and
when you look at there are some great
studies that look at longitudinal
training changes in different position
groups
on the same football team and what you
see is that the linemen
always start the intervention with
higher body fat percentage and it's not
close it's usually a pretty big
discrepancy from
you know the the skill position groups
and the linemen
as a former lineman i object to that
terminology uh i find it
belittling and uttering linemen are
skilled too
that that's i mean honestly that is
extremely true like
when you lyman are incredible i don't
want to get on too big of a tangent but
there was a a guy on my wrestling team
in high school who was a really
exceptional lineman
um so he wrestled at like 270 pounds he
ended up winning a super bowl so he was
pretty good
um but there was this one moment where i
was watching one of his matches and he
did something
where he was so light on his feet and so
nimble
i was like i could never do that and i
wrestle at 140 pounds
and i was just like yeah these linemen
are skilled like oh yeah
it's remarkable but skill positions
cornerback receiver etc
so when we look at the longitudinal
training changes the linemen
in the the selection of studies i found
that that did report position group
specific changes
they tended to gain as much or more lean
mass and they they tended to have
either similar effects on fat mass or
larger reductions in fat mass while they
were gaining
similar or greater amounts of lean mass
so you know
without calculating a p ratio i mean
they had leaner gains happening
uh in the studies that i looked at so
you you could say oh well i can maybe
find other st i didn't try to cherry
pick but i didn't
have access to the entirety of all
observations and football players
try to do a good job getting some
studies together but even if you know
maybe this is uh inadvertently
cherry-picked but
i think the the challenges it would
indicate that this relationship that's
hypothesized
is not strong enough to
really to really impact these numbers
across
contexts right so if if we can find
enough areas where it doesn't seem to
pan out
it's really hard to justify that this
relationship is strong enough
and consistent enough to get really
worked up about you know if we can find
so many counterpoints
so um another area of literature we can
look at like i said
is looking at longitudinal body comp
changes in people who have lost weight
and are regaining weight
uh as i mentioned when we look at the
physique athlete literature
weight regain after a competition i mean
talk to somebody who's done it
it ain't lean gains like if you're a
natural bodybuilder and you're coming
off you know from from being
stage lean the big challenge there is
how do we get back to a healthy spot
where our hormones are functioning
normally without gaining a ton of fat
right off
right off the bat so it's really the
inverse where we're trying to say
how do we deal with this crappy p ratio
coming off of this
this competition diet and then extend
extending out from that into less
extreme cases of
you know untrained folks who are losing
weight and then regaining it
either intentionally or unintentionally
again it's usually
a worse p ratio or an unchanged p ratio
but we do not see that literature
where they lost some body fat and then
said oh sweet now that you're regaining
weight
it's a whole bunch of muscle yeah i mean
quite famously
when people partake in yo-yo dieting
they don't get bigger every time i mean
they might get bigger
in terms of like total mass but you know
it's not like oh man i've been yo-yo
dieting for two decades and
now my arms are tearing out of my shirts
yeah and of course someone could push
back at that and say well the yoyo
dieting literature those aren't people
that are lifting
and then it's like yeah but like the
entire evidence base for this hypothesis
is in people who don't lift
you know so it's it's kind of a yeah so
moving on um i think
you know at that point we had looked at
all the stuff that was kind of already
pre-packaged and kind of sitting there
in the literature and this is your idea
and i was really annoyed
that uh you told me after mass was after
the mass article had been written
because i was like damn that's a good
idea well i mean
i could tell you were working hard you
see you seemed stressed out
uh and if i would have dropped that in
like the comments when i was peer
reviewing your article i i would have
been saying like
hey eric here's a here's a project i
don't know how it's gonna pan out
it's gonna take you at least a dozen
hours uh
please get this done in the next three
days yeah so i
i decided to be nice for once yeah it
could not have been done well
in the time that was available so it's
it's it's good that we revisited
later but basically what we did here and
you were really helpful with this in
terms of coming up with the the damn
idea which
in hindsight is so obvious i hate myself
for not thinking of it
and also aggregating the data getting it
put together but we're like listen
there are literature there are
studies that document changes in body
comp in response to lifting
and in those studies people have
different body fat at the beginning
so it's not like this is an unobservable
thing that will ah
you know sometimes there's research
questions you're like damn i guess we'll
never know
like unless somebody does a huge study
and it's like well
this this evidence exists we just have
to go find it aggregate it and then
analyze it and so
we gathered uh the challenge here was
we need to find studies where we can get
the individual data you know
looking at the averages isn't going to
cut it for this particular question
so we were able to gather the individual
data for seven studies and this is i
think
a really a really exciting
extension of our talk about open science
if
more data sets were openly available we
could have put together
you know 36 studies hundreds of
participants
and you could do this for other
questions that come up like it would be
a really exciting thing
um but anyway we gathered seven studies
yeah just for context
uh when i was looking for open data sets
i have
um i have a database of 89 studies that
i know
report uh changes in
all of them report changes in strength
and like two-thirds of them report
body comp or hypertrophy changes that i
pulled together
for a data project i worked on last year
i started by looking at all of those
studies none of them had open data sets
uh then i thought like oh
what studies do i know of off the top of
my head that have open data
that got me two uh and then
there's like through uh
there's like databases you can search
where um
like uh data sets are uploaded to like
supplemental
materials so i did like several keyword
searches
uh and just spent a cumulative probably
five hours just like scrolling through
papers with supplemental material
and came up with exactly three more
studies that had open data
and then mike zordos hooked us up with a
data set
and eric helms hooked us up with a data
set uh so like realistically
when eric said like 36 studies that's
definitely lowballing it
of all of the of all of the research
that has been done
in our area that reports changes in body
comp
after a resistance training stimulus
there have to be hundreds of potential
papers oh yeah
that we could uh put into a model if
they all had open data
uh and out of those hundreds of
potential studies
we were able to get data for seven of
them and two of the seven were just
because we knew the people who collected
it
uh we were able to find five
actual open data sets out there in the
wild
um which is terrible yeah
yeah and it's it's like you know it's
not anybody's fault it's just like
that's never been the culture
of the field is to make data open yeah
also
all of which is to say if you hear seven
studies and you're like ah man
wish they had more studies we [ __ ]
tried yeah
yeah i like i said i i spent probably
five hours
just like just tabbing through search
results
looking for these data sets and they
there just aren't that many out there
yeah and if we get more we'll jam more
into the model
i mean it's quite it'll be quite easy to
do that but
uh for this kind of preliminary look at
it we've got seven studies with uh i
think 161
uh participants that are represented
among those
those seven studies yeah 161. and so
you can imagine what we're trying to do
here on the x-axis
we've got the baseline body fat
percentage of the individuals
and then the question is what goes on
the y-axis um
p ratio itself gets challenging because
one of the scenarios that comes up is
recomposition so
someone who gains lean mass but actually
loses weight because they also lost some
fat mass
during the intervention and that would
hardly be considered
a negative thing or an unfavorable
change in body composition based on the
context
of what the studies are trying to do
with the intervention
but but of course in that scenario your
p ratio becomes negative
which is weird and introduces weird
patterns in the data
so what we did uh and greg you came up
with this which is great
it's i'm going to call it like a lean
gains metric
you know basically the the change in fat
free mass
minus the change in fat mass and so this
metric
in kilograms basically rewards you for
gaining lean mass and then
essentially penalizes you for gaining
fat mass in terms of your score
so so if you gain a bunch of lean mass
and lose some fat mass you're going to
have
a positive high number uh so so
hopefully that makes sense
did i explain that well enough i think
so yeah so you know if the number's high
it means you had some
really lean gains yeah and just just to
clarify further why we couldn't use p
ratio
like eric said basically as soon as any
number becomes negative
things get kind of screwy so a situation
where you
lose lean mass and gain weight which is
a very bad outcome any situation
where you gain lean mass and lose weight
would both give you a negative number if
you were calculating like a conventional
p
ratio and it would be indistinguishable
right um
so like basically like middle of the
road outcomes
make quantitative sense as p ratios but
both
very very good outcomes and very very
bad outcomes
look identical when you're calculating p
ratios
which don't give you the statistical
properties that you want to see
when you're actually trying to answer
these questions
it kind of highlights that idea of
you've got this kind of beautiful
theoretical model in your head that's
just kind of you know
theory driven and you've got this
beautiful beautiful curve in mind
and then you get real data into the mix
and you're like well wait a minute like
this is more complicated than that yeah
it gets a little messier
so so that's the way that we approach
the analysis
and there's a few ways you could look at
that right so you could do regular
regression and you know just look at you
know
as body fat goes up at baseline how does
that affect your lean gains
outcome and you can look at that within
each study
individually and what we generally found
within each study individually is
basically nothing
uh a few kind of weak correlations
that that are pretty meaningless some
positive some negative and then
two that were actually like kind of
notably positive
which would go in the one that was very
notably positive
one was statistically significant yeah
and so what that would mean is
when we say positive it means if you had
a higher
body fat percentage at baseline you had
a better outcome in terms of this lean
gains metric you made
a higher lean gains value throughout the
study so this actually goes
completely opposite the direction of
this kind of hypothesized p
ratio idea so that's if you look at each
study individually a little bit of
evidence
saying that the p ratio idea is actually
in the wrong direction
and then other studies saying this this
p ratio thing probably just doesn't
matter too much
when you look at these outcomes so
another way you could do it is say
well let's do regular regression and
just jam all these studies into one
regression model
and just treat them all like they're
from the same study
and if you're a statistician and you
heard that and you spit out your
your coffee don't worry there's more
coming later
i know we we address it but if you were
to do that
then what you find is
overall in aggregate
the higher body fat you have at baseline
the better outcomes were
you know so so there was a positive
slope that was
statistically significant indicating
that the higher body fat you had at
baseline the better
outcomes were for this lean gains metric
and the p-value
was uh 0.000007
11 0s there now if you're a statistician
like i said you're saying
oh that's terrible you can't just assume
that those are
independent data you have to deal with
the fact that those are seven
independent clusters from seven
different studies
and uh i did a lot of reading uh i
borrowed my girlfriend's uh hierarchical
regression textbook
and so uh you know we accounted for that
we did a linear mix
model with random intercepts for study
and so of course with that approach we
are going to get more robust results
that are a little bit more
solid and statistically defensible
but the the slope was actually like
almost identical
the p-value was 0.007
still significant uh the the
relationship was the same but this is a
much more
statistically robust way to do it so
now the statisticians are back on board
and they've got a sigh of relief
so again the idea is the higher body fat
people had
at the beginning of the study uh the
better their outcomes were for this lean
gains metric again
the the relationship going the opposite
direction of this
p ratio idea in terms of being
inhibitory uh you know if you have high
body fat percentage
now um we dug deeper uh
and so you can get to the to the heart
of this relationship
instead of using that lean gains metric
as the outcome
i did a model where we looked at the
change in fat free mass
as the outcome and a model where we use
the change in fat mass
as the outcome now when you look just at
the change in fat free mass
with body fat percentage on the x-axis
there's no relationship
it is meaningless the slope of zero
body fat percentage of baseline did not
impact the amount of fat-free mass that
these people gained
in any direction at all when you look at
fat mass as the outcome it tells a very
simple story
people who had higher body fat
percentage at baseline tended to lose
more fat mass
throughout the intervention and and
that's it
and so so so basically
um kind of painting in broad strokes the
the accretion of lean mass was similar
but people with higher body fat levels
were basically gaining
as much lean mass in a slight to
moderate calorie deficit
as people with lower body fat were at
maintenance right more yes
yeah the people with higher body fat
percentage did not have any impairment
uh in terms of their ability to put on
lean mass going through the same exact
intervention
but they were more likely to have a bit
of a recomposition effect where
as they were gaining that same amount of
lean mass they were in fact losing some
fat mass along the way so again
that is indicating that in terms of this
whole p ratio idea it was actually
better gains for the people who had
higher body fat percentage at baseline
but
it's not that hypertrophy was being
blunted or potentiated or anything like
that it's just that they were more
likely to be experiencing this kind of
recomposition due to the loss of fat
mass and so
uh i wouldn't necessarily contend
that we have the perfect model and you
know
we did it because what you find with
this and again this gets back to the
original thing i said
the default null hypothesis is that
this p ratio thing probably doesn't
matter in terms of inhibiting or
potentiating hypertrophy this idea that
having high body fat at baseline is
going to
potentiate or hinder your your lean mass
gains the null hypothesis is that that
shouldn't matter
and so when you when you set out to do
something like this and say i'm going to
disprove this idea
it's hard to to really disprove
something
but we're kind of in a position where
we've talked about several different
lines of research that all seem to be
completely equivocal or leaning in the
opposite direction
of this idea that you should lose fat
before you bulk because it's going to
enhance your p
ratio and give you significantly leaner
gains and so
based on all this all these lines of
evidence i would propose
a simpler and much more parsimonious
model
and the model is the following weight
gain
is dictated by the magnitude of
overfeeding just
how positive is your energy balance
that's weight gain
now the proportion of weight gained as
lean mass
is going to be dictated by the presence
of a stimulus
for lean mass gain and so in the context
of a resistance training study that's
going to be your training intervention
and probably the magnitude of uh your
surplus too
absolutely yeah uh so you know and that
helps us explain why we see that p
ratio in people recovering from anorexia
is there
is a massive stimulus for the accretion
of lean mass because of
the prior atrophy of critically
important lean tissues
and so it but in the context of healthy
individuals doing resistance training
this comes down to
are you feeding yourself enough to make
gains and are you training well
you know do you have a solid training
stimulus uh
and and so that's that's pretty much it
you know uh the lean mass gains are
going to be
you know directly tied to the the
stimulus for lean mass gains and whether
or not the nutritional intervention is
permissive
of lean mass gains and then any
additional body fat gained it really
comes down to how much energy
positive energy balance is left over
after all the energy consuming processes
have kind of used up their energy and so
you might be listening to that model and
saying well yeah that's
obvious and to me that's kind of the
point
like i i think this whole p ratio idea
is adding complexity
where we need not add any complexity i
think this stuff
not just where we don't need it but
where it's actually inappropriate
yeah i i i was being charitable but if
we're throwing
that out but no i mean i i think we are
in a position where there are several
lines of evidence that lean against it
um and
no really relevant lines of evidence
that lean for it unless
we have a massive blind spot that we
haven't considered and i'm totally open
to that but
the way i see it this is a hypothesis
that
has very questionable foundations in the
evidence
there's a lot of evidence leaning
against it and
i i think the much more simple model is
much more
compatible with the evidence that we do
have
makes sense to me all right so you've
got a research review segment right
i do yeah so uh in the
most recent fireside chat episode we put
out when we
were kind of looking back at the year in
research one of the things i mentioned
that um where there's been a fair amount
of work in the past year
uh that i kind of came around on pretty
recently
is the concept of ischemic
preconditioning um
and i didn't really elaborate on that in
the podcast because that's
not what we were doing in that segment
and several people message me and
they're like
ischemic preconditioning i've never
heard of that what is that
uh and so uh yeah i'm gonna talk about
it a little bit
um this is uh in some way a bit of a
sneak peek
for the issue of mass that's going to
come out february 1st
uh i have an article on ischemic
preconditioning in there
um so yeah uh ischemic preconditioning
uh so let's just break that down first
ischemic relates to ischemia cutting off
blood flow
and preconditioning doing something
before something else to condition
yourself for the thing to come
so the what what we're doing here is
pretty straightforward we
we are conditioning muscles via ischemia
to hopefully perform better in a
subsequent exercise bout
so the way that this is typically done
in the research
um is you'll use generally in research
context they'll use a tourniquet but in
a practical context you could use
a knee wrap or something similar you
you would wrap it tight enough to cut
off both
venous and arterial blood flow
and that way it's different from blood
flow restriction training so in blood
flow restriction training generally
you're only trying to cut off venous
blood flow but not
arterial with ischemic preconditioning
you want it to be tight enough to cut
off
arterial blood flow as well you could
verify that
by checking for the absence of a pulse
so if you're doing this for your arms
you put the wraps on tight and if you do
feel a pulse
in your wrist still the wraps need to be
tighter
if you don't feel a pulse you're good
same thing with the ankles if you're
doing this
on your legs so you occlude
all blood flow for five minutes then you
remove the wraps
just chill out for five minutes allow
those tissues to reperfuse
and then you repeat that process three
or four times
so three or four rounds of ischemia and
three or four rounds of reperfusion and
then
once you're done the wraps come off and
then it's time to exercise
um so that may sound
weird and it's about to sound weirder so
content warning i'm about to discuss
some old research so trex can put some
time stamps on here
where if you want to skip ahead uh and
not hear about very bad things being
done to dogs you don't have to
uh but anyway with that out of the way
uh ischemic preconditioning was first
studied
um by a researcher named murray in 1986
i do not know how this idea came to his
mind but
uh basically what he did is he had two
groups of dogs
open their chest cavity up um and
in one one group of dogs he did
uh ischemic preconditioning procedure
for uh one of the major arteries
supplying the myocardium
uh the the heart muscle um
and so one of those major arteries uh
occlude all blood flow for five minutes
re-perfuse for five minutes occlude for
five minutes re-perfuse for five minutes
repeat four times
uh so he did that in one group of dogs
the other group of dogs
no ischemic preconditioning whatsoever
and then in both groups of dogs
cut off blood flow through that artery
for 40 minutes
that induces a heart attack you're
you're cutting off
blood flow to the heart so that caused a
myocardial infarction
and then what they did is compare the
size of the affected tissue from the
infarction
in the this ischemically preconditioned
dogs versus the dogs that hannan
undergone
preconditioning and what they found was
very striking
uh the size of the infarct was reduced
by about
75 in the dogs that had just undergone
ischemic preconditioning
they also looked at some blood flow
variables and found that
things like collateral blood flow didn't
really seem to be different between the
groups meaning that
you know the the ischemically
preconditioned dogs weren't
protected uh against the 40 minutes of
ischemia by
like collateral blood vessels shunting
blood to that area of the myocardium um
you know apart from like the the
occluded artery
uh so it seemed to be driven by
uh metabolic changes within the tissue
itself that had been ischemically
preconditioned to basically make it more
robust
against the prolonged uh ischemic threat
that was to come um so anyway that's
that's the first study that stumbled
upon this phenomenon
and since then it's been studied in uh
other animal models and in humans for
protection against heart attacks
basically
it's not going to stop you from having a
heart attack but a ischemically
preconditioned heart
if it does have a heart attack basically
the damage
will be less severe following it
so they've known about that in the
context of heart stuff
since the 80s in the 2000s
researchers started looking into this in
the context of exercise
and most of that early research was done
in the context of aerobic exercise and
there was a systematic review that was
published last year i believe that
that summed up the ischemic
preconditioning research again
largely in aerobic exercise and it
basically found that uh
it was beneficial for improving exercise
performance
more so in sedentary and recreationally
trained people than in competitive
athletes
um but it did seem to have a pretty
notable and reliable effect
um and relevant to
stronger by science podcast listeners
there have been seven studies that have
looked at the
effect of ischemic preconditioning on
resistance training performance or
recovery
so there was a study that just came out
last month by da silva
telus and colleagues what they did is
um had subjects do three sets of bench
press and three sets of leg press to
failure with
several different conditioning or
like several different warm-up protocols
preceding them including ischemic
preconditioning
sham pre-conditioning an active warm-up
uh
dynamic stretching and
maybe oh yeah just a control condition
um
and basically they found that uh when
when the same
like when this group of subjects had
previously undergone ischemic
preconditioning
they managed about an extra rep or two
per set
for the squat and bench press so there
was
a you know approximately a 20
increase in total volume performed
across those three sets to failure
um last year or or earlier this year one
of the two
uh carvalho and colleagues uh did an
ischemic preconditioning study where
they had
subjects do a single set of knee
extensions to failure with 85 percent of
1rm
following ischemic preconditioning or
not ischemic preconditioning and they
found
again the ischemic when the subjects
underwent the ischemic preconditioning
condition they completed about 20 25
percent
more reps um going back a little bit
further
novaeus and colleagues uh had subjects
uh trained male subjects to three sets
to failure with 80
of 1rm on bench press leg press pull
downs
machine hack squat shoulder press and
smith machine back squat
and looked at total volume completed
across
all of those exercises again finding
ischemic preconditioning
improved total volume completed uh going
back a little bit further
friends and colleagues uh used ischemic
preconditioning
prior to an eccentric training protocol
and looked at both reductions and
strength
from the start of the protocol to the
end of the protocol and also
various markers of muscle damage and
recovery from training
finding that preconditioning um ischemic
preconditioning
mitigated the strength loss pre to post
exercise and also
um mitigated some of those markers of
muscle damage they looked at
uh paradise duchene
i'm sure i'm pronouncing that wrong i
assume it's french
looked at the effects of ischemic
preconditioning on
losses in maximal isokinetic knee
extension
torque after a fatigue protocol
in male and female subjects finding
again
ischemic preconditioning um
mitigated performance loss mitigated
strength loss in the male subjects but
not the female subjects
interestingly and then finally two
studies by
maricolo and colleagues also
used samples of trained males
one of them found that ischemic
preconditioning
improved volume performance compared to
a control condition but notably not
when compared to a sham ischemic
preconditioning condition so basically
same general protocol but you just don't
uh
you just don't put the pressure cuff on
tightly enough to occlude blood flow
so it did beat a control condition but
not a sham condition
uh and that is probably the most
negative finding we have to this point
and then the other study by maricolo and
colleagues
looked at the effects of ischemic
preconditioning versus
a sham procedure on
multiple days of uh of volume
performance
and basically found that ischemic
preconditioning did improve
volume performance the first day it was
used but not the second day
suggesting that maybe the benefits
dissipate
over time so overall there there are
again seven studies in this budding body
of literature
uh six out of the seven have broadly
positive findings
the most negative one again uh it beat a
control condition but not a sham
condition
um that's not a huge concern because
several of these other studies included
a sham condition
and real ischemic preconditioning did
beat out sham
preconditioning and another pretty
notable thing about this body of
research
is one of the things one of the things
we see
when a lot of bodies of research are
developing
is you initially see protocols used on
untrained subjects and then
you know maybe you have a half dozen
studies on untrained subjects before
they actually get some trained subjects
in the mix
which is perfectly fine but you know
less useful to
people in our general audience cool
thing about this body of research is of
the seven subjects five out of the seven
use trained subjects making this body of
literature
though it only contains seven studies
generally
probably more generalizable to our
audience than
than many bodies of literature would be
uh so a few things to note about this
and just
lingering questions the first is do the
effects fade over time
so one of those studies by maricolo uh
basically tested the effects of
ischemic preconditioning twice finding
that it was
helpful the first time but not the
second time so
there is a chance that you know it's
it's kind of a one-hit wonder
and not the type of thing that you would
benefit from doing
before every workout but again i
wouldn't necessarily
take that to the bank because that has
only been found in one study
another open question is are there sex
differences
in terms of responses to ischemic
preconditioning
um again only one study has
compared the effects in the strength
literature and it did find
benefits in males but not females
but again i don't know how much stock to
put in that yet
i i sk skimmed
like skimmed the studies included
in that systematic review i told you
about that
again included mostly aerobic training
studies
basically to see like ah you know maybe
if there's a half dozen studies in the
aerobic training literature comparing
males and females
if a lot of them did find sex
differences then it would be like okay
maybe
this one finding in the strength
literature is more reliable and durable
but you know if there's half a dozen
that find no sex differences
in the uh aerobic training literature
then like yeah okay maybe this is
just kind of a false positive um there
were
no studies in the aerobic training
literature
as far as i could tell that compared
males and females uh
they were either all male samples are
all mixed sex samples that i don't
believe
uh compared to the male and female
subjects
so that that's still an open question
whether ischemic preconditioning is
beneficial for
female lifters as well
and then another question that there's
some
evidence kind of indirectly related to
uh is how far away from training can you
do
your ischemic preconditioning and still
accrue benefits
so one of the things about this is you
know you're doing a five minute on five
minute off protocol three to four times
so basically you're signing up for a 30
to 40 minute warm-up protocol
if you wanted to do this immediately
before training
so one possibility is like oh maybe if
you could do ischemic preconditioning
earlier in the day at a time that's
convenient like i don't know maybe if
you just
have time at your lunch hour that you
wouldn't mind just like
putting some knee wraps around your arms
and legs uh
and then you're gonna work out right
after school or right after work
could that potentially be beneficial in
the
cardiac ischemic preconditioning
literature
they find that the positive impact of
ischemic preconditioning seems to last
for around
six hours uh suggesting that like maybe
you could do it in the morning
and then lift at lunch and still see
benefits or maybe do it
during lunch and then lift immediately
after school or work and still see
benefits
that's what some of the cardiac stuff
would potentially suggest
but that hasn't been actually verified
in
exercise literature yet so that's that's
something that that i'd be interested in
seeing research on just
you know to to maybe make this more
practical for some people
um but anyway very very cool concept
i don't know how many people
would actually do it again just because
you're you're basically signing yourself
up for a 30 to 40 minute warm-up
protocol
um but the effects do seem to be uh
like reasonably large in magnitude at
least in context of
uh ergogenic activities one might engage
in to try to boost
acute performance it's worth noting
there aren't any longitudinal studies
yet so we don't know if
that acute increase in performance would
actually lead to more hypertrophy or
larger strength gains over time
uh but at least again when compared to
other acute ergogenics
uh the effects seem to be fairly large
and fairly consistent
uh again with six of the seven studies
having broadly positive findings
um so anyway if you wanted to give this
a shot
it's i think interesting enough to at
least try out
a couple notes i would make uh safety
should be paramount
one of the things that i think kind of
trips people out is thinking like oh
if i'm cutting off blood flow to my
muscles for five minutes that must be
bad for my muscles
and like your muscles will be fine uh
what you would potentially need to be
concerned about
i i know that sounds flippant but like
you know basically
uh research on the safety of of
full tourniquets which is what we're
talking about here
um that that's mostly looking at like
you know if you get shot or have like a
major
injury to a limb uh and a medic has to
put you in a tourniquet before you can
actually get
um you know like a medical procedure
done on you
um how long can you have a tourniquet
before
the tourniquet is is likely to harm you
more than the blood loss will
uh and you you can actually keep a
tourniquet on for
for quite a long period of time before
you need to worry about damage to your
muscles
um so when we're talking about five
minute bouts of
full occlusion that that should be
perfectly fine for your muscles
what you would need to worry about is
potential nerve damage
um so in general that shouldn't be that
much of a concern the
two ways you could get in trouble is if
you have your
your knee wraps or if you do have a
tourniquet your tourniquet
um very inappropriately tight so like
you do need to get it pretty tight to
occlude arterial blood flow but if you
go
way tighter than is necessary you can
put too much pressure on a nerve
and and potentially damage it the other
thing you need to look out for
is if the device whatever it is that
you're using to occlude blood flow to a
limb
if it's too thin that is basically
putting more pounds per square inch
on the nerves that it's passing over um
so like if you use knee wraps you should
be fine but if you use like
one of those thin elastic exercise bands
you might get yourself into trouble
and basically like if you're if your
nerves aren't happy they're probably
going to tell you like you might feel
some shooting pain you might feel
numbness you might feel tingling
if you get any nerve related symptoms
like that stop
um and at minimum
try re-wrapping and re-wrapping a bit
looser uh
and if you're you know somewhat
conservatively wired
ah just stop you know this this isn't
the type of thing that's going to make a
night and day difference in your
training um but anyway
that's just a safety precaution if you
do want to give this a shot
but uh yeah i mean it's i i think a
really really
interesting thing um
oh a couple things worth noting i
haven't talked about mechanisms yet
the the full accounting of the
mechanisms by which ischemic
preconditioning would improve
exercise performance we don't have that
yet but some of the
known mechanisms by which it works is
one
things related to to nitric oxide
signaling
so you you put a limb in ischemia and
then
once you allow it to reperfuse you have
a pretty big
uptick in nitric oxide signaling
a lot of vasodilation increased blood
flow to the tissue
another thing you get um is adenosine
receptor
activation which um has like a
a host of downstream effects that is
thought to be
the way by which caffeine exerts its
ergogenic effects on exercise
so basically it's it's kind of like a
caffeine supplement and like a
quote-unquote pump supplement
all rolled into one um which i think is
kind of neat
the the adenosine though would be acting
locally correct
uh yeah yeah because normally like the
majority of what
is going on with adenosine and caffeine
is centrally mediated so
that's an important thing to to clarify
well don't
don't people also think that some of the
local effects of caffeine
are due to like calcium related effects
downstream of
adenosine signaling absolutely yeah and
there there is some really fascinating
work
in uh tetraplegic individuals with
caffeine showing that there
there does seem to be effects on
muscle activity and muscle contractile
function that is fully
separated from from the central nervous
system
but i just wanted to to clarify it that
people are not going to get any of these
central effects that they associate with
canada oh yeah yeah so it's not like
they're going to have
increased alertness and wakefulness or
anything like that yeah yeah that's
uh a very good caveat uh
it it might have similar local effects
in the muscle to caffeine but not not
the same central effects caffeine would
um and the third mechanism by which it
might exert an effect is
just like a general increase in
mitochondrial efficiency
due to uh some pretty gnarly mechanisms
that
you probably don't care about unless
you're really into biochem
so i won't bore you with them but but
basically there are
some known mechanisms by which it exerts
its effect but we we don't know
all of the potential mechanisms yet but
yeah anyway i think it's
uh you know there's some mechanistic
underpinnings for it and there is a
grow a small but growing
overall quite positive and consistent
body of literature
in mostly trained subjects finding uh
you know fairly notable acute effects on
volume tolerance and fatigability during
training so
uh yeah if you wanted to give it a shot
this is
one of the more promising ergogenic
interventions that that we've been
seeing in the literature recently
that's fascinating stuff and i'm very
i'm very proud of you
because as you and i both know we record
with a team of lawyers in the room
and they were really nodding in approval
when you mention all the stuff about
safety i like that
so obviously this is safe enough to be
justifiably done in lab-based settings
but of course the underlying assumption
is that you're applying it correctly
so if you are going to try this make
sure that you are being really careful
about making sure you're doing it the
right way
yes um but yeah the lawyers were really
loving that so that's good
sick um okay so we're relatively short
on time i do want to address
a few pretty practical q a questions um
you know just to kind of i want to make
sure that we cover several different
topics in the uh
in the episode so uh just a nice little
rapid fire q a segment here
where i'm gonna answer a couple uh
practical questions but greg please feel
free to chime in some of these i think
you'll have some
uh some input some feedback on them so
the first one the first two actually are
from benjamin
siciliano and number one is very quick
and easy to answer
because we've already talked about it in
this episode so the question is can you
gain muscle while eating at maintenance
calories if you're getting adequate
protein
and you have body fat to spare and that
essentially
is kind of the main finding of of the
models we put together for that p
ratio question which is absolutely that
idea of recomposition of
gaining muscle while simultaneously
losing fat
uh that has absolutely been observed in
in all sorts of individuals in our our
data set there are many of them
uh so that that can definitely happen
and really what it comes down to
is you know what is your body
composition what is your training status
what is the training stimulus and is
your nutrition
adequate uh to basically allow
hypertrophy to occur in the absence of a
large caloric surplus
and in many cases that is uh you know
there are all sorts of
instances where that can be observed so
someone with a little bit more body fat
to lose at the beginning
uh you know they're they've got a great
training stimulus that based on their
training status
is adequate to induce hypertrophy
they've got
all their you know they've got all the
nutrition they need to support muscle
growth
despite the fact that they might be
eating at maintenance or even a little
bit
below maintenance so absolutely that is
possible
now this question i think is fun this
this one is also from benjamin
do you think that new lifters might be
better off
by initially avoiding an evidence-based
approach
to training and nutrition in other words
could dreamer bulks
bro splits ego lifting and things like
that
confer some physiological and
psychological adaptation adaptations
that science
just doesn't understand yet uh
greg do you want to take the first crack
at this or should i uh
i i can take a crack at this yeah i'm
interested in your perspective here
uh yeah i mean so the
first thing i'll note is that
uh i think it kind of depends on what
your definition
of quote unquote evidence based is
um and and the question is like are you
talking about things that
have been verified to work in the
research
or are you talking about things that
particular people recommend that are
branded and marketed with evidence-based
used
as a marketing term um and i think that
those are oftentimes two very different
things
uh and i often think that using
evidence-based as like a
descriptor of oneself for marketing
purposes is basically just code
for uh hey i'm gonna tell you to do
something that's really really
complicated
and i'm going to try to convince you
that you need to do something really
really complicated
in order to maximize your results and
that's kind of like my competitive edge
in the market
i kind of think that that's what's often
conveyed when people
talk about something that's quote
unquote evidence-based and
from my perspective like no if you're an
untrained lifter a lot of that [ __ ] is
completely unnecessary
um like as long as you're training hard
and pretty consistently like you're
gonna be fine
um you know you you you might need to
make things a little bit
more uh squirrely and complex at some
point but like
yeah first couple years in the gym as
long as you're doing something pretty
consistent
it's it's not really going to matter all
that much um
and then the things you mentioned
specifically dreamer bulks bro splits
ego lifting um so
starting with bro splits
um this is so that's
one of the reasons i i started with that
initial caveat for like what one means
by evidence based
uh because like you know basically
if you ask the question like can is
there
plentiful evidence showing that bro
splits can
result in strength gains and hypertrophy
like yeah
absolutely a hundred percent and a bro
split just for context
is it safe to say that that's basically
training with a frequency of
hitting each muscle group once per week
is that pretty much the yeah agreed upon
yeah so
i think so yeah um so so like yeah
there's
there's some research showing that uh a
slightly higher frequency like hitting
each muscle group two or three times
per week might be a little bit better
but like
if you just want to ask like what what
does uh
what does science verify can work for
people
uh there's there's plenty of evidence
showing that
that bro splits can work perfectly fine
um
uh the the one that really jumped out to
me is
ego lifting um so here i'm gonna go
well off the uh the the quote
quote-unquote evidence-based
talking points and probably just like
the general
things that people often consider to be
good advice
i'm i'm a pretty big fan of ego lifting
i gotta say
um so i guess it kind of depends on like
what one means by ego lifting
so uh if if you're talking about like
you know
letting your form absolutely go to [ __ ]
or like cutting your reps to
allow you to lift more weight like you
know half squatting
um reversing your bench presses like
four inches off your chest or something
like that like
yeah yeah i'm not a big fan of that
version of ego lifting
um but i think oftentimes what people
refer to as ego lifting is like ah like
that person's pushing themselves
too hard and like
i don't know dog i think that's
generally fine
i don't think humans are made of glass
i don't think you're fragile um is maybe
they're some degree of
increased risk of injury by uh you know
pushing yourself too hard to get that
last rep or add another five pounds to
the bar
maybe but like i'm kind of of the
opinion that the increase in relative
risk isn't particularly large
and i think that like the mindset that
that version
of ego lifting engenders is not a bad
mindset to go to the gym with
um where you know you're going into it
with the expectation that you're really
gonna get after it
uh and you know you're trying to do more
than last time more volume more weight
more something
um so like yeah i'm i'm a big fan of
that
speaking as a coach uh if
if two people come to me and they're
alike in every way except their
psychological makeup and one of them
uh just really wants to overdo it in the
gym like push
every set closer to failure than i want
them to
do more volume than i want them to and i
have to pull them back versus someone
who i'm
like constantly having to encourage to
do more
the the first person there 99 times out
of 100 is
is probably gonna make better gains
short term medium term long term
um that's just been my experience so
like
yeah if as long as you're not talking
about like really
cheating technique or you know doing
something
uh that that would generally be
considered like poor
form uh when you're talking about ego
lifting if it's more like going to the
gym
cocky and like expecting yourself to be
getting better and really really getting
after it
i think that's totally fine and i think
that um
it builds uh
the sort of mental fortitude that sets
you up for better gains down the road
it's
it's way easier to to have to pull
yourself
back than to force yourself to train
harder
in my opinion and what about the final
one which is dreamer bulks
uh yeah um
i mean i think we've talked about this
on the podcast before
uh and i think our opinions are the same
uh
scientifically it doesn't seem like a
great idea if your
caloric surplus gets too big uh
your since this is the p ratio episode
your p
ratio is going to go to [ __ ] uh the
training stimulus you're imposing
is sufficient to build a given amount of
muscle and lean mass and
you're just putting way more calories in
your system than you need to
uh accomplish that like yeah
it's uh i think physiologically it's not
the best idea but
one of the things we've noticed is that
like most lifters who've wound up being
successful have dreamer bulked at some
point in in their lifting career
uh and and i think like so i think the
value of a dreamer bulk
is really for people who
are starting to feel like they're
stagnating i
i think that it does help a lot of
people like break through that initial
plateau
and realize for themselves that they can
make it to like
th the quote unquote next level um
like i experienced that i uh
so the first power lifting meet i did
i competed at 165 and then you know just
from
touching weights i i naturally built
some muscle
filled out the 181 class
and just kind of stuck around the 181
class for a while
and initially made some gains and then
eventually like hit a wall pretty hard
[Music]
and i i was thinking like oh man
like maybe i'm not as cut out for this
whole powerlifting thing as i thought i
was
uh i've only been really really training
seriously
for maybe about a year and like i'm
already hitting a wall pretty hard
this is not good um and then i just
decided like
well i didn't decide i i came across the
uh
the famous elite fts article about jm
blakely
uh and his very
unorthodox nutrition practices i'll i'll
put it like that
um the line that always gets me is uh
when you're having your large pizza
put any kind of oil on it other than
motor oil yeah isn't that the one
yeah yeah yeah so to be clear i did not
follow
the jm bleakley diet to a tea or
anything like that but
it impressed upon me the idea that like
hey man
if you want to get big and strong you
gotta eat a lot
and so over like maybe a four month span
i went from like 183 to about 216
um which to be clear was way faster than
i should have gained weight
but i
way broke through those plateaus i had
like i came out way stronger on the
other side and it made me realize like
hey these numbers that i thought uh
might be around where i'd stick for a
while uh
no like i had way more in my tank than i
thought i did and that kind of opened up
the idea in my head like
how much further can i go so it did kind
of like
unlock that in me mentally via
helping me get past that first um
somewhat demotivating plateau i found
myself in
could i have done the same thing by uh
you know overeating to a smaller degree
and not dream or bulking
i'm sure i could have absolutely um
but also like i don't know dog i was 16
uh and didn't know anything about
nutrition and
uh so you know if i was trying to go for
a
controlled methodical book i just didn't
know enough
to to have been able to accomplish that
at the time so like
the dreamer bulk did for me what it
needed to uh and i don't regret it
so yeah i mean the one thing you can say
about a dreamer bulk is that you
definitely don't leave gains on the
table
correct or food you don't leave food on
the table either
correct just eating and making gains and
probably putting on more fat than you
need to
from a physiological perspective but you
know i
i agree with with most of what you said
there
um you know i think the most important
thing you can do
when you're just getting into lifting is
you know don't leave gains on the table
because you're afraid to put on you know
a pound of fat i think that's really
counterproductive
and another thing is like you got to
fall in love with it
i really think that's the best thing you
could do in your first year or two of
lifting for sure
and so like for me i got into the bro
splits
fell in love with it made a ton of gains
ate a lot it was awesome you know like
and i think
the one thing that holds people back and
they think oh i got to do everything
perfect from the start
i think a lot of people believe that the
the like beginner gains
they think that that relationship or
that phenomenon
is purely temporal in nature like there
is a time window yeah
that that's a really really good point
there is a time window
in which your beginner gains occur and
if you do stupid stuff during it you
miss it
and that couldn't be further from the
truth your beginner gains are
hey my muscles are feeling tension for
the first time
and and then they grow and you even if
you're doing a pretty sub-optimal
approach when you begin
you'll get some degree of beginner gains
but then if you
refine your approach and make really
substantive improvements in your
approach to training
you'll make another round of beginner
gains whether that occurs
six months into your training career or
six years into your training career
and like for me a great example is guess
what when i was 12
i probably could have trained better
that's when i started training and it
was stupid
but when i was like 18 i really got into
it and i made another
round of beginner gains six years into
my training career
uh and then i also had a pretty lovely
dreamer bulk around that time
uh and i kind of chuckled when you
mentioned the idea of like kind of
opening up your eyes and saying like oh
the i'm able to push past some of those
those barriers and limitations during
that dreamer bulk
i've mentioned this on the show there
was a time during my dreamer bulk
and i went from like 150 to like 195
in a pretty short period of time hell
yeah and
uh there was a time there when i thought
like hmm
am i going to be on the olympia stage
[Laughter]
if so i better put the pedal to the
metal
and uh yeah i mean i mean there was
times there where i was you know
squatting heavy and hard four days a
week for months on end and like
if you're not ego lifting to get through
that what is wrong with you
like what is what is compelling you to
go in and do those kinds of workouts
like
like you said i mean if ego lifting is
just saying screw it i'm gonna go
kill myself in the gym and use insane
form that that totally breaks down
that's a bad idea but but there's got to
be some
degree of ego kind of driving you
towards some of those more rigorous
workouts and the more rigorous training
blocks
and if it's not there i just don't know
if you're going to have the
the intrinsic nastiness to get into the
gym and just kind of
really leave it all in the gym so so i i
think there is a time and a place for
letting your ego push you a little bit
in the gym and
and yeah i mean the last thing you want
to do when you're starting
out is say oh i've got a finite window
here
to make my beginner gains i have to have
this ultra methodical approach
that removes everything i enjoy from the
process like
that that's a losing combination in my
opinion
okay one other question here that i want
to answer and this is this is the good
stuff
people know why they come to this
podcast oh god i i know what it's about
to be
it's to get recipes from me
so the person with the question is named
ben
i believe it's a different ben than the
previous two questions
and the question is what are some
recipes for high volume but low calorie
foods
so that you can feel full when you're
trying to get shredded and they came to
the right place but these are actually
serious uh answers i think these are
pretty good to be honest
um so you know you go to you know
chipotle or something like that you get
a burrito bowl
people tried to make everything out of
cauliflower that was a trend
i don't know if they're still trying in
most cases it failed
cauliflower cannot be made into
everything but it can be made into rice
cauliflower rice is very very good so a
great
option is a a burrito bowl
using cauliflower rice put in some
vegetables that are sauteed put in some
shredded chicken
some some sauce or whatever some salsa
you're good to go
that is a great meal and you can use
greek yogurt as a sour cream substitute
and it is honestly quite good
um number two buffalo chicken
you can make a buffalo chicken type dish
very very lean if you use shredded
chicken breast
hot sauce with a little extra cayenne
pepper
some red pepper in there and instead of
using ranch dressing
if it's late in prep and you're really
desperate i know it's not ideal
but you can use ranch spices without all
the the creaminess and whatnot
and you can get pretty close with some
good buffalo chicken
with that combination of ingredients
it's not perfect but you're hungry
anyway you're going to love it
a nice simple meal is chicken breast
with just a little bit of italian
dressing and then
i think it's called california veggie
mix but basically that's what they call
it
at the grocery store on the bag but it's
just broccoli
cauliflower and carrots kind of chopped
up very basic but that's a really nice
that's a meal that got me through some
hard times when i was you know doing
some bodybuilding stuff
egg white omelette with veggies you can
never go wrong
that's a great option lean beef
with broccoli and soy sauce very lean
meal
that is quite delicious you can make
yogurt out of greek yogurt with some pb2
peanut butter
and some sugar-free chocolate pudding
mix mix that all up it's a really nice
kind of peanut butter chocolate pudding
substitute and if you want to drizzle
some sugar-free chocolate syrup on top
you can do that it's
really not bad and then finally this is
my most controversial one
i saved it for last this was a really
good
thing at first and then i got carried
away i flew a little too close to the
sun
i'll admit that but you do oats you cook
the oats the way you normally do make
them a little bit more runny than you
normally would
and then you mix in a pumpkin puree
so you've got this kind of oat pumpkin
mixture you put in pumpkin spice and
splenda
that is delicious i haven't gone off the
rails yet that is very good
now i was eating that during a
a pretty serious diet and the calories
had to come from somewhere and i admit
i made some mistakes it was an error in
judgment but i started just kind of
phasing out the oats
and then one day i looked down and i was
like oh my god i'm just eating pumpkin
puree at this point
so that that one got a little bit away
from me but but honestly
if you've got enough calories to to get
some of the oats in the mix there
that's a pretty solid meal a really good
fall flavor
you know you could trick yourself into
believing that you're eating pumpkin pie
uh so so that's some good stuff if i
could just add
one uh very simple addition
you could make if you're making anything
with ground beef
if so i mean you could you could shred
cabbage yourself if you have way too
much time on your hands
or you can just get bags of coleslaw
veggies
at the store so just like pre-shredded
generally
cabbage and like maybe a little carrot
but really the cabbage is what you're
looking for just like
pre-shredded cabbage uh if you toss
some shredded cabbage in with any ground
beef dish that you're
that you're cooking uh all the way up to
like a one to one ratio
you can basically double the volume of
what you'll be consuming
it doesn't affect the taste or texture
all that much
it does certainly impart some flavor of
cabbage which i personally tend to like
if you don't like cabbage
tough luck this tip's not for you uh but
yeah you can
you can come pretty close to like
doubling the volume
of any ground beef thing you're making
by
uh by tossing some shredded cabbage in
and
i i personally find it quite good uh
even if i'm not trying to stretch
calories like i just like it
tastes it tastes nice in my opinion yeah
and
i've mentioned my on the topic of
coleslaw i've mentioned
my low calorie coleslaw recipe before
and it's it's actually good
it's just uh the shredded pre-made uh
you know cabbage and carrot mix and you
put in some greek yogurt you put in a
little bit of splenda you put in a
little bit of dijon mustard
mix it all together it's good stuff it's
really good
um okay you weren't horrified by my uh
by my contribution so i'm gonna
call that a win no those uh i mean you
you know how i feel about you just
eating
pumpkin puree yeah but but everything
else you mentioned
um those are those are perfectly
reasonable things to eat when calories
are really tight
nice all right so to play us out uh
we've both got a little something for me
it's a realization that
i i'm ashamed that i didn't know this
all along
um so a couple years ago so this year
in the new year's episode we didn't
really talk about smart goals much
because i was just like you know what
i'm more focused on building some habits
and
i don't want to make it ultra specific
and super quantified i don't want to i
don't want the goal to be that
regimented i just want to build some
good habits and that's been working
really well
but in a prior episode around new year's
time
we talked i talked about smart goals and
i didn't know the
origin of where smart goals came from
me being an optimist very naive i
assumed it was just some
well-intentioned folks saying hey
let's help people achieve their goals
and accomplish their dreams and stuff
you know we want to support the
individuals
boy was i wrong i learned from helms the
good doctor
that uh the smart goal actually
originated in a corporate setting
and i just can't view it the same way
anymore so
now when i think of a smart goal i think
of i think of
some corporate structure just grinding
its workers to the bone
trying to extract more labor from them
it just ruins the concept for me
so um i retract i condem i disavow and i
fully separate myself
from all past uses of the smart goal
concept
doesn't mean it can't be used
effectively but it just puts such a sour
taste in my mouth because i had a very
different uh
totally baseless idea of where it
originated i never thought about where
it came from and the the corporate
setting just ruins it for me
yeah it's just like a straight line down
from uh
what was his name uh frederick winslow
winslow taylor
like the the idea of taylorism like man
humans are these organic beans but like
we're currently
in the middle of the second industrial
revolution what if humans were machines
and we could squeeze every last bit of
efficiency out of them to make our
uh production lines work a little faster
um
yeah just uh just really bleak
dehumanizing [ __ ]
yeah and and the other you've probably
heard the smart goal acronym used
several different ways like uh
different things kind of inserted for
for the acronym
and i think a lot of that is because it
it is originally for a corporate setting
where some of the original acronym terms
just don't make sense
like like the a is assignable and like
for most people that
it just doesn't make sense so they kind
of adapted it to make it this like hey
use a smart goal for your behavior
change model and it's like
it just ruins it for me but that doesn't
mean it can't be used effectively but uh
i was
very appalled to learn that but greg
what do you got to uh to play us out
here
uh yeah so to to stay on the topic of
cooking
one of the things i've been really
getting into recently
is making flavor pastes which
is more appetizing than it sounds
basically all you do
is you get a mix of fleshy vegetables
so things like onions peppers tomatoes
carrots celery um some mix of those
things depending on
what what type of paste you're trying to
make what general
vibe you're going for so you start with
some fleshy vegetables
some spices and some herbs you start by
just
roughly chopping everything and throwing
it all in a blender or food processor
until you're dealing with a relatively
homogeneous
liquid i guess and you pour all of it
the liquid the
the bits of of plant matter all of it
uh into a non-stick pan with a little
bit of fat in it
and you start it over high heat
[Music]
and to start with you're just trying to
get most of the liquid out
once i would say once the liquid has
reduced by
between half to two thirds give or take
you want to kick the volume down to low
medium low
uh basically a temperature where nothing
is going to
burn uh before you have a chance to
really tend to it
and then you just stand there and uh and
just keep stirring and stirring
great time to put something on tv to
watch as you mindlessly stir your pan
a good time to put on a podcast maybe
even this podcast prior episodes we have
a great back catalog
uh just a suggestion and you just keep
stirring
until virtually all of the water is gone
uh everything is starting to caramelize
and the first thing you'll notice is a
big scent
transformation so when you blend up a
lot of those vegetables especially
if you have some alliums in the mix so
some onions some shallots some garlic
something like that
when you blend everything up uh when you
smell it
it's probably initially going to i
wouldn't say smell
offensive but it's going to be pretty
sharp it's going to be pretty pungent
pretty acrid
uh and over time the flavors will really
mellow out they'll start getting sweet
as everything caramelizes down
and basically you just keep stirring
until
uh virtually all of the liquid is gone
and you have a
thick paste left over um
basically you know you're getting close
when bubbles stop
and there's just kind of like a bit of a
hissing and just like a
uniform like sheet of steam coming up
out of the pan but it's it's gotten too
viscous to actually bubble
anymore uh that's when you know you're
getting pretty close
so with a flavor paste basically you can
just
make yourself a little flavor bomb that
you can use to start
any dish super easily um
and so like this is gonna take i'm not
gonna lie to you
you're probably going to be standing
over a pan stirring it for the better
part of an hour if not
over an hour so there there is some time
investment on the front end
but then you have just this beautiful
paste
that carries you know
90 of the flavor that you might want to
put into a dish
moving forward so it it makes cooking
so much easier and more efficient until
you run out of it and you know you can
uh
go with different pastes with generally
different vibes for
different dishes so uh currently we have
uh
some indian and sty uh indian inspired
paste
uh in the in the fridge so um
the base is tomatoes onions garlic
uh red peppers cumin coriander cardamom
mustard seeds cinnamon and allspice
uh and maybe some other things i'm
forgetting but those were the big ones
uh simmered it down and it's just a
great
uh red curry paste and i made
the best goddamn pot of lentils i've
ever had in my life with this stuff
um and and the really good thing about
it is it's
like you could you can make it in bulk
um since the first
part of it you're doing over high heat
like the amount to make
uh like four dinners worth of pace
versus
versus like a dozen is basically the
same because like
a lot of what you're trying to do is get
the water out and you can do that pretty
quickly over high heat
uh so it scales pretty well uh and it it
freezes
really well too so like you know you
could spend
a day and just like take three or four
hours and make three or four
great flavorful pastes uh and then
anything that you're gonna be sauteing
you just like rehydrate it in a little
bit of water anything that you're gonna
be
uh boiling so like a pot of beans pot of
rice something like that just
just throw some flavor paste in uh and
man it's so good i feel like
this doesn't sound as appetizing as it
should because paste
doesn't seem like that appetizing of a
word uh
but but take my word for it it's great
um
basically like any uh any
dominant kind of flavors of the world
that you want to go with you can make a
flavor paste for so like you know if you
wanted to
go with like a french mirepoix
you could start with just celery onions
tomatoes and then
you know if you want to throw some some
thyme in there if you want to throw some
rosemary in there you can
but yeah you can just uh throw a
mirepoix in a blender
blend it down cook it down until
everything's nice and caramelized and
sweet
and then you know if you're making some
sort of sauce and you want
some some sweetness and some vegetable
notes in it just throw some mirepoix
paste in it's going to be [ __ ] great
um and really like
your your imagination is the only thing
that limits you with this technique
and i think the beauty of it is it's
really hard to go wrong because once you
cook it down enough and everything
caramelizes even if you don't end up
hitting the flavor profile that you're
aiming at
it's still gonna be delicious like it's
it's very very hard to screw up
i think the only way you could screw it
up is if you just happen to get it
way way way too spicy um
but i mean like i don't know
don't do that uh but yeah
it's it's been uh really really
useful for nights that i want to make
something really good and i want to make
it quick
uh like i don't want to spend the time
you know roasting things down
caramelizing things developing flavors
like
a lot of good cooking one of the most
important
ingredients is the time that you invest
into the dish because
complex flavors take take a while to
develop and with this
you can get a lot of those same complex
flavors
you know a month ago and then you can
just like put a little dollop of the
paste in
into whatever you're making and it can
really
really just transform a dish and make
weeknight cooking
very delicious and also very very quick
and efficient
so anyway uh you know just just a basic
technique i would like to share
and i would strongly recommend you give
it a shot
all right so that does it for this
episode and
as we mentioned earlier we are going to
take a little podcast
break but during that break we will
still exist
virtually in the stronger by science
facebook group
and in our subreddit and of course we
will still be sending out research
review emails and stuff like that so
make sure you join
the facebook group and the subreddit i'm
gonna link both of those in the show
notes
and uh until we're back from our break
we'll be happy to stay in touch with
everybody
there so uh yeah we'll be back
eventually but in the meantime we'll see
you
on the internet thank you for listening
to the stronger by science podcast
if you enjoyed the podcast be sure to
sign up for our free newsletter to get
concise breakdowns of relevant research
as well as 28 free training programs
for all skill levels and all schedules
we hate spam just as much as you do
so we'll only email you when we have
something really interesting to share
with you
you can sign up for the free newsletter
at strongerbyscience.com
newsletter or just go to the stronger by
science homepage and click the free
programs button at the top
if you want to join in on the stronger
by science podcast conversation
be sure to check out our facebook group
and our subreddit the links for both are
provided in the description of today's
episode
finally please remember that we are not
medical doctors or registered dietitians
so before you make any changes to your
exercise or nutrition habits
be sure to check with a qualified health
care professional
once again thank you for listening and
we will be back soon with another
episode of the stronger by science
podcast
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you